quand une issue maintenant key sayed en
pleine offensive contre la corruption le
président n'a pas hésité à prolonger
l'état d'urgence jusqu'à nouvel ordre à
face au chant ty économique politique et
social hérité de ces dernières années
une mission qui semble compliqué sans
soutien que lui apporte la population
ainsi que l'armée tunisienne a les
précisions dans notre correspondant à
tunis la semaine chez bis
critiqué par l'opposition pointé du
doigt par les islamistes d'ennahda qui
assaillent est seul contre tous peut
compter sur le soutien de la population
tunisienne dont 95% plébisciteraient son
action selon un sondage de sigma conseil
réalisée le 17 août dernier en plus
d'une large partie de la population le
président peut également compter sur le
soutien de l'armée dont il est le chef
ainsi que celui des forces de police et
pourtant depuis la révolution 2011
l'armée s'était toujours tenu à l'écart
des conflits et politique le 26 juillet
dernier au lendemain des annonces du
président elle a appliqué les ordres du
palais de carthage en encerclant le
parlement pour en interdire l'accès un
rapprochement loin d'être soudain
puisque le chef de l'état n'a eu de
cesse de tisser des liens étroits avec
les militaires et ce depuis son
accession au pouvoir en 2019 alors que
le chef du gouvernement démis de ses
fonctions hichem mechiche y croyait
qu'il était immunisé grâce à une
ceinture de sécurité politique au
parlement le président kaïs sayyed a
commencé à broder une ceinture de
sécurité d'un autre genre il a partagé
sa colère contre la situation politique
dans les casernes des militaires et de
la police en mai 2020 alors d'une visite
aux élèves de l'académie militaire
d'offendorf h 10 ty sayyed a ainsi
pointé les failles de la loi électorale
la corruption politique et la perte de
légitimité du parlement en pleine crise
sanitaire le président tunisien a même
confié aux forces armées une partie de
la campagne de vaccination après l'échec
du gouvernement de hichem ni chichis un
travail de longue haleine qui a permis
aux locataires de carthage de s'assurer
aujourd'hui le soutien de l'armée pour
mener à bien les changements qu'il
souhaite opérer dans le pays